[Music]
it's probably the most high-profile
routine physical in political history
the White House physician Ronnie Jackson
spent a full hour a little over and I
think in the White House briefing room
today taking questions about president
Trump's physical and mental state it was
a pretty remarkable series of exchanges
here's part of it do you believe he is
fit for duty
absolutely man look like I said you're
gonna put an elliptical machine next
event room and you're gonna use it what
does that look like he limited to one
strip of ice cream now has died at all
that suggested that could be related to
centures does the president wear
dentures to address drug addictions drug
addiction no no he has he has no drug
addiction who eats McDonald's chicks and
all those diet cokes and it never
exercises is it as good a shape as you
say is it it's called genetics well does
the elaborate theater over the
president's health say much about the
president or about the press Fox senior
political analyst for huge joins us
tonight but thanks for coming on so if I
were doing if I if Trump runs again and
I were in charge of as as which of
course I won't be but if I were I
wouldn't brag about the achievements to
defend myself against the attacks I
would just run a tape of reporters
asking does he wear dentures
what's his life expectancy what's his
waist circumference circumference I
think that would get him reelected no I
don't know about that Tucker but he got
a pretty clean bill of health that's for
sure and remember part of this is a
function of the fact that he told
Admiral Jackson his doctor who by the
way was previously the doctor to
president obama and president george w
bush and enjoys a very very high
reputation he told him to go out and not
refuse any questions to answer all
questions so you know the press thing
this is open season is pretty soon into
dentures and eating habits and there was
one exchange with questions about his
waistline and all that it didn't
probably didn't measure his waistline
because there were no
there was no reason to do it he's not a
tailor to everything and then of course
probably most importantly consider the
current Fuhrer over his mental condition
the president had asked although it
wasn't clinically indicated that this
doctor give him a cognitive exam and he
gave him one which which concluded
because he hit he got thirty questions
out of 30 correct that his cognitive
faculties are very much in order and
that he's sharp and on it and and and
coherent now that's not a psychiatric
exam it should be noted but it's a
pretty good test of whether somebody's
sort of mentally fit and he passed that
with flying colors and there was some
you could detect a certain skepticism
and disappointment in the room about it
but the doctor was pretty emphatic and I
think you know to any any fair-minded
viewer pretty convincing
so I remember during the last
presidential campaign when Hillary
Clinton had some kind of collapse in New
York I think it was on the anniversary
of 9/11 we were explicitly instructed by
The Washington Post not to ask about her
health when did the rules change well I
think well I think we did it we did end
up asking better health but I did and
there were not a lot of answers
forthcoming and you know to be perfectly
fair about it Tucker I mean one is
entitled to have a confidential
relationship with one's doctors about
yes consider your mental condition and
the president has waived all that no
president that I've ever heard of has
ever done anything like that and of
course we know going if we go back far
enough you come across presidents like
President Roosevelt who concealed his
his paralysis to the greatest extent
possible so that you know most Americans
didn't even know about it until after he
was dead and the press was complicit in
that all the way through cuz reporters
would cover him and saw him every day
knew it but never reported it so that's
how much the atmosphere has changed and
of course you know and at this stage
it's open season I think the president
obviously felt that if these questions
were gonna be raised and he is in
remarkably good health owing apparently
two good genes for a man of 71 who's no
63 and 239 pounds he wanted all of that
out there so he was partly responsible
for this but - but the you know the the
thing went on for 56 minutes which
really it's a precedent it really what I
mean it really was forensic unbelievable
britt hume thank you it's great to see
you tonight
you bet Tucker thank you